a warning this report by our
correspondent Adele Robinson contains
some flashing images
a campaign to reform the media over
allegations of intrusion and illegality
now the first senior Royal to enter the
witness box in over a century win or
lose he wants to embarrass both the
media and certain members of you know of
the royal family and the Royal household
through these legal actions this for him
is is a crusade as he sees it others
think of it as a morbid obsession
and it's part of just one of Prince
Harry's four legal battles against
British tabloids this latest against
mirror group newspapers who deny
allegations of phone hacking and illegal
information gathering between 1996 and
2011. there's a fairly strict limitation
period normally that you need to bring a
claim like this within six years or six
years you your knowledge the events so
what is currently Up For Debate is what
he knew and when and whether information
that he says he got at a later stage he
could have known earlier
[Applause]
it's been an explosive year for Harry
off the back of the Netflix documentary
publishing his Memoirs amid headline
grabbing interviews all critical of
press intrusion but Behind These doors
at the high court this will be the first
time that Prince Harry has had far less
control over the narrative lawyers for
the mirror group will be pushing and
probing and challenging every one of his
claims and the Duke of Sussex will have
to prove that illegal phone hacking and
blagging led to more than 30 articles
about him
but he doesn't stand alone a cast of
celebrities are joining this and other
legal cases against a raft of newspapers
a throwback to the levison inquiry which
focused on media culture and ethics it
will be interesting whether the palace
and the way in which they have dealt
with the media in the past and certainly
Harry would say that the palace have fed
the press that they've fed and planted
Stories the extent to which the palace
by association feels somewhat in the
dark and if they then change their
relationship and practices with the
media thereafter
Harry's refusal to settle may make him a
formidable opponent but his exposure is
risky nevertheless The Showdown of
prince versus press has only just begun
Adele Robinson Sky News